bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actu politique est aussi
parlementaire avec à mes côtés kathia
gilder bonjour catllar jean miquel mais
cette semaine dans l'actualité c'est une
victoire pour un ancien premier ministre
la maman de jean marc ayrault est
adoptée au parlement baisse de la cg
pour les salaires les plus modestes très
peu de députés dans l'hémicycle pour ce
vote
il faut dire que le gouvernement n'était
pas forcément favorable ce nouveau coup
de canif dans la loi et rats après les
sénateurs les députés ont confirmé en
commission leur volonté de distinguer
publicités et informations sur le vin au
sein du gouvernement la disposition crée
un désaccord entre les milices de la
santé et le ministre de l'économie et en
fin d'émission document exceptionnel
valéry giscard d'estaing ancien
président s'est confiée à frédéric
métaireau pour lcp une interview
surprenante où l'ancien président lui
même quelques larmes en évoquant un
poème de baudelaire et nous accueillons
marielle de sarnez bonjour à jour vous
êtes députée européenne vice présidente
du modem et bras droit de françois
bayrou il y a beaucoup d'actualité pour
vous cette semaine n'est vous
n'échapperez pas à la tradition des
députés parlent de vous un petit
portrait au micro de françois chevré
c'est une femme libre
qui a des idées bien arrêtées combative
engagé volontaire une femme de
conviction qui changent pas de
conviction tous les matins elle est très
engagée au sein de sa famille politique
auprès de françois bayrou et je suis
très heureux qu'on ait réussi à faire
l'union en ile-de-france avec elle
autour de valérie pécresse et du mal à
compenser quelque chose quoi parce que à
la fois la eu des positions par le passé
qu'ils étaient les positions d'ouverture
héritière d
des fondateurs du centre républicain
aujourd'hui on la retrouve avec d'autres
pécresse tirant cette joyeuse troupe
il ya une constance et engagements et
dans cet engagement notamment
auprès de monsieur ou
toujours été un appui très flou
il faut
une équipe youri indisponible et
je ne peux que saluer cela parce
la constance est important en politique
ce qui ressort c'est ça sans jugement
très rapide et sa notorité constante
engagé libre vous avez toujours
revendiquer votre liberté
alors vous partez en ile-de-france allié
avec valérie pécresse
ce choix ne vous rend pas un peu moins
libre sachot de liberté que j'ai fait et
c'est un choix vers la région que j'ai
fait je pense qu'il faut vraiment du
changement dans la région pour que ça
change écouter tous les franciliens qui
prennent leur train qui prennent leur
rer tous les jours tous ceux qui ont des
problèmes d'emploi tous ceux qui
cherchent des stages dans la région tous
ceux qui ont des pme à développer et je
pourrais continuer la liste est longue
ben je pense qu'on peut vraiment faire
mieux mais beaucoup mieux et je pense
que valérie pécresse sera une bonne
présidente de région s'il est élu et moi
je ferai tout pour qu'elle soit élue
parce que c'est quelqu'un de très bien
dans ce portrait on entend aussi équipe
a dit solide avec françois mais on ne
vous est jamais venu l'envi l'idée
d'aller voir ailleurs mais moi je suis
si je travaille avec françois bayrou à
s'écouter depuis longtemps maintenant si
cette traversée que au fond mais oui
mais moi je me retrouve dans
l'engagement qui est le sien nous
pensons à peu près la même chose alors
après on peut avoir des sensibilités
différentes pas voir parce qu'on a des
parcours bas qui sont pas évidemment pas
les mêmes dont bien plus de la famille
centriste moi je viens de plus de la
famille on va dire giscardienne mais on
croit tous les deux que oui il faut un
centre fort dans ce pays on croit tous
les deux qu'il faut changer des choses
profondément
on a tous les deux je crois une forme de
d'éthique enfin en tous les cas moi
c'est comme ça parce que ça c'est vous
c'est comme ça que je vois la politique
est au fond faire équipe être engagée
dans un combat est déterminé à changer
les choses croire en un idéal ben je
crois que c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous
a un sens elle reprend les deux lectures
jeux la louve a justement commencé par
ces élections avec un petit tour
d'horizon
les dépôts des listes ce s'achevait ce
lundi le premier tour aura lieu le 6
décembre prochain tour de force et tour
de région avec tout de suite
alix plichon dans un peu moins d'un mois
les français sont appelés aux urnes pour
le premier tour des régionales ce midi
marquer la date limite de dépôt des
candidatures est pour l'emporter
la droite et le centre ont fait le choix
de l'union les républicains sont têtes
de liste de treize régions tandis que la
normandie le centre val de loire et la
bourgogne franche comté sont conduites
par les centristes seuls territoires où
l'union n'a pas pris la martinique où
chaque parti présentera ses propres
candidats
en cas de victoire 70 % des places
éligibles iront aux républicains et 30%
à lui d i
du côté de la gauche l'heure est à la
désunion
le parti radical de gauche reste un
allié fragile pour le ps et quelques
responsables écologistes ont quitté leur
parti pour pouvoir figurer sur les
listes socialistes
mais le parti du gouvernement se trouve
isolé pas question pour le parti de
gauche ni pour le parti communiste de
faire cause commune avec les socialistes
mais les alliances entre écologistes le
parti de gauche et les communistes ne
sont pas pour autant lisibles elles se
font et se défont d'une région à l'autre
en languedoc-roussillon midi-pyrénées
les trois parties présentent une seule
liste commune alors qu'en bretagne
le front de gauche et les écologistes
s'affrontent des accords à géométrie
variable qui risque d'embrouiller les
électeurs le fn quant à lui est en ordre
de marche
le parti à constituer des listes dans
toutes les régions celle de dissidents
pour les régions midi pyrénées languedoc
roussillon et provence alpes côte d'azur
où le maire d'orange jacques bompard
forte une liste d'union de droite
rassemblant quelques déçus du parti de
marine le pen le parti frontiste
pourrait bien l'emporter dans trois
régions la provence alpes côte d'azur le
nord pas de calais picardie et l'alsace
champagne ardenne lorraine un scrutin
capital pour marine le pen qui souhaite
en faire un tremplin pour ses ambitions
nationales
alors voilà pour ce tour d'horizon mais
l'actualité cette semaine elle est venue
et bien du premier ministre manuel valls
qui prône une sorte de fusion des listes
dans le nord pas de calais par exemple
si jamais le front national devait
gagner
écoutez le point
istres il s'est exprimé au micro de
public sénat il a ce fait une sorte de
rectification le soir du premier tour il
ne faudra écarter aucune hypothèse et
tout faire pour empêcher le front
national de gagner une région et nous
verrons dans quelle condition en
fonction du résultat c'est tout
simplement ce que j'ai voulu dire
n'écarter aucune hypothèse et ce qui
écarte aujourd'hui une hypothèse ni une
hypothèse mentent aux français il faudra
bien trouver si cette situation se
présente il faudra bien trouver une
solution le soir du premier tour
moi j'ai mon pays je ne veux pas que des
régions tombe dans les mains de
l'extrême droite ça ne serait pas bon
pour les petites gens dans les régions
ça serait très négatif ce serait
terrible pour l'image de la france j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
donc le plus haut possible au premier
tour rassembler la gauche pour le
deuxième tour tout faire pour que
l'extrême droite ne prenne pas une
région
marielle de sarnez dans cette interview
on n'a pas écouté
l'intégralité mais manuel valls dit ça
serait faire preuve de cynisme de dire
que l'idée de la fille jours ce n'est
pas possible
écoutez moi je crois depuis longtemps
qu'il faut changer le modèle politique
français mais je pense que là il a tort
dans la manière notifier les choses dans
le tempo et dans le calendrier dans la
gestion des régionales qui est la sienne
pour vous je pense qu'il faut sur les
grands dossiers sur les grands sujets
comme on était capable de faire les
allemands
je pense qu'il faut et on parlera de la
présidentielle après la prochaine
présidentielle
faire bouger des lignes et avoir des
forces politiques qui restent ce
qu'elles sont la droite républicaine le
centre une gauche que j'espère la plus
réformatrice est ouverte possible qui
soit en capacité sur un certain nombre
de grands objectifs de semaine d'accord
c'est pas de maison commune c'est au
fond se dit qu'est ce qui serait bon
pour le pays
il faut que nous classe politique voilà
on arrête de dire systématiquement que
les uns les autres
je crois que j'ai joué l'hymne et ma
mère
dit les choses c'est super politicien
c'est à dire il est général en chef
d'une armée
c'est l'armé des socialistes qui se
battent contre l'armée on va dire des
ump des républicains il dit écoutez je
voudrais vous dire moi général en chef
de l'armée jeudi il va falloir que vous
alliez pactiser tous ensemble tout ça
n'est pas crédible
tout ça n'est pas raisonnable tout ça
n'est pas sérieux quand ça leur a valu
d'ailleurs tu n'en sais rien j'en sais
rien je comptais sur vous pour maîtriser
parce que je n'arrive pas bien à
comprendre
alors après il reste une question si les
socialistes et c'est grosso modo ce que
les sondages donnent arrive largement
distancé en troisième position ou plus
loin encore et qu'il ya un vrai risque
dans la région nord pas de calais
évidemment qu'il faudra appeler et moi
j'appellerai à leurs responsabilités et
leurs responsabilités ça sera de se
retirer sur le champ la logique non mais
moi je vous dis ce que je pense
écoutez il est premier ministre il est
chef de bataille c'est très difficile je
trouve de faire de la politique de cette
façon là c'est parce qu'elles sont
faites il dit
mais est ce qu'il le fait pour dire aux
socialistes vous demande pas à vous
retirer je vous dis comme ça vous aurez
quelques élus tout ça tout ça n'est pas
sérieux n'est pas raisonnable et c'est
vrai que je pense que marine le pen se
frotte les mains et bien droite ne sais
pas si je n'ai pas mon envie
à droite ce n'est ni vous vous êtes pas
pour moi pas pour moi moi c'est le
centre l'a toujours été clair et vous
serez question avec françois bayrou bah
oui mais écoutez moi je ferai valoir et
les choses je ferais exactement valoir
ce que je pense et ce que nous pensons
et je pense dire quoi et j'espère pour
sera entendue écoutée s'il ya une liste
de droite qui est complètement distancé
et qui se retrouvent symétriquement dans
la même position qu'une liste de gauche
peut-être ça arrivera c'est parce que
donnent les sondages aujourd'hui sur
mais admettons que ce cas d'école existe
il faudra faire la même chose il faudra
faire un appel à la responsabilité des
uns et donc je n'aurai pas la formule
qui a été appliquée par nicolas sarkozy
à savoir le minima j'aime pas trop vite
socialisme
consommez pas trop cette formule du
ni-ni c'est quelque chose qui moi comme
centriste
j'aime bien un centre affirmé le ni-ni
ça ne va pas alors je vous ramène à
l'actualité parlementaire à mardi
puisque la loi evin a été à nouveau
égratigner un amendement a été adopté en
commission à l'assemblée nationale pour
assouplir l'interdiction de la publicité
sur les alcools pour certains fabricants
loi evin est un frein à leur activité
la mesure adoptée divise le point avec
faustine de saint geniès c'est
l'amendement de la discorde au sein du
gouvernement
son objet assouplir la loi evin sur
l'alcool pour permettre la promotion des
régions viticoles et du patrimoine
français introduit et voté par les
sénateurs dans le projet de loi santé en
septembre dernier
cet amendement a été maintenue hier en
commission des affaires sociales à
l'assemblée nationale au grand dam de la
ministre marisol touraine
je ne change pas de position je trouve
ça assez désastreux mais sa voix a bien
du mal à porter elle est contredite par
celle du ministre de l'économie qui
brandit ce matin l'argument de l'emploi
c'est pas quelque chose qui contrevient
aux objectifs de santé publique
c'est toujours pareil il faut
proportionnée les choses on défend la
santé publique et loi evin a été une
formidable avancée il faut la protéger
et après simplement il faut permettre à
certaines régions et aux emplois qui
vont avec en france de défendre leurs
intérêts de faire la promotion de ce
qu'on appelle en effet le no tourisme un
nouveau désaccord au sein du
gouvernement
françois hollande lui même avait appelé
à clarifier la loi evin en juin dernier
à bordeaux
mais il se garde bien de prendre parti
entre ces deux ministres est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la loi evin existe encore
est ce que ce qui a été voté c'est la
victoire des lobbys avec la bénédiction
d'une partie des députés
ben je trouve que ce n'est pas très sain
là ce qui est en train de se passer en
plus j'ai vu les petites combines à
l'assemblée ont fait démissionner
deux parlementaires d'une commission
pour en faire venir deux autres qui eux
sont favorables à détricoter la loi evin
enfin tout ça c'est de la toute petite
politique
écouter aujourd'hui il ya de la
publicité pour les terroirs et pour le
vin ça va respecter la loi evin parce
que c'est quand même une question de
santé publique majeur c'est parce que
c'est parce que la fin de la même il
faut je suis contre ça je suis contre ça
et je trouve que les de ce point de vue
là les parlementaires le gouvernement je
n'arrive pas bien là non plus à suivre
regardez quand vous allez vous prenez
tous les hebdomadaires français combien
de fois dans l'année il y en a déjà qui
font de la publicité sur le vin donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut assouplir tout ceci
ça existe déjà ce qu'il faut c'est
renforcer l' explication auprès des
jeunes en particulier
et moi je suis du côté de ce point de
vue là de l'exigence en matière de
comédie de katia c'est la victoire un
peu des loupes depuis quand on voit qu
emmanuel macron dit lui-même que il n'y
aura pas de dommage pour la santé je
t'aide qui connaît pas bien la loi evin
la regarde de plus près donc certains
députés en votant ce genre d'exposition
sont irresponsables ou données disons
que ce n'est pas raisonnable
ou alors peut-être qu'ils font une
espèce de d'électoralisme il ya des
moments où il faut être un petit peu
courageuse avoir résisté à ça ça peut
encourager l'alcoolisme des jeunes ce
phénomène qui est souvent ce qu'il faut
c'est lutter contre ça ce phénomène
d'alcoolisme des jeunes il est terrible
et moi je préférerais que les
parlementaires passent leur temps plutôt
à regarder à s'attendre de mesures qui
soient des mesures intelligentes en
direction des jeunes de prévention
plutôt que d'aller voter comme ça en
catimini des mesures qui détricote une
loi tout ça n'est pas sérieux alors
parlé d' emmanuel macron vous avez
peut-être vu cette actualité cette
semaine et la ville de suresnes qui a
décidé de payer ses fonctionnaires au
mérite il n'en fallait pas plus donc
pour que le ministre de l'économie
réagit de façon même positive parce
qu'il est plutôt pour cette mesure
c'est une réforme qui est déjà en cours
et qui suscite aussi quand même encore
des polémiques hausse avec elisa
bartholomé faut-il changer le mode de
rémunération des 5,6 millions de
fonctionnaires pour deux ministres du
gouvernement
la réponse est oui moi je pense qu'il
faut accroître la part en effet de
mérite
la part d'évaluation dans la
rémunération la fonction publique c'est
une façon de moderniser pour évoquer
entraînement à un régime indemnitaire
qu'ils aient une reconnaissance vous
savez dans ce dossier favorable les
choses soient très claires on paie les
fonctionnaires en partie au mérite vous
y être favorable au oui je suis
favorable à une condition c'est qu'il ya
une discussion aux organisations
syndicales et que y compris pour les
travaux en équipe on puisse avoir aussi
cette prime où cette forme d'avancés en
3d l'année prochaine la ville de
suresnes en banlieue parisienne va mener
une expérimentation en ce sens les 1300
fonctionnaires verront leur rémunération
varier en fonction de la qualité de leur
travail
l'idée de généraliser cette
expérimentation est fraîchement
accueillie à gauche on voit bien les
difficultés qui a mesuré le mérite
qu'est ce que c'est le mérite c'est le
diplôme qu'on a eu c'est l'heure à
laquelle on part mais ça il ya des
réglementations pour ça c'est la
motivation dans le travail comment
comment
mesure ça je pense que monsieur macron
devraient aller faire un stage chez les
fonctionnaires qui ont des petits
salaires pour voir comment ça se passe
alain terme ça serait sûrement très
intéressant pour pour sa connaissance et
son expérience à droite les prises de
position des deux ministres font l'effet
d'un cafouillage problèmes que ça pose
c'est celui cohérence du gouvernement
c'est à dire le ministre de l'économie
qui intervient sur la fonction publique
sans l'accord de la mise la fonction
publique qui découvre ses déclarations
en direct à la radio
bref tout ça est assez invraisemblable
et ce à la relève de la capacité ou de
l'autorité prétendu de monsieur valls
l'a aussi quelle autorité pour un
premier ministre un premier ministre qui
reste silencieux sur le sujet pour
l'instant le gouvernement n'a pas
l'intention de toucher au mode de
rémunération des fonctionnaires
alors cette prime au mérite vous de ça
existe ça existe déjà on sait depuis
depuis toujours calé primes pour les
fonctionnaires c'est d'ailleurs une des
difficultés pour une future réforme des
retraites par exemple la retraite par
points où il faudrait intégrer dans les
salaires les primes donc on sait bien
que ça existe il ya un traitement
individualisé on va dire des
fonctionnaires si on peut l'améliorer si
on peut le perfectionner moi je suis
favorable à ça mais il faut que ce soit
sur des objectifs au fond que les
fonctionnaires eux mêmes qu'ils
participent à définir ses objectifs pour
que les objectifs soient claires qui
soit bien identifiée qu'est ce qu'on
attend d'un invité de questions demande
et en même temps je n'ai pas envie de
les pointer du doigt des c'est à dire
sous-entendu ah ben il ferait pas bien
leur job
ce que je veux dire il ya des
fonctionnaires qui gagne très très peu
et qui gagnent très très mal leur vie et
pour qui c'est extrêmement difficile
donc dans le privé aussi on peut haïr
exigent des la qualité du travail et
donc ne parlait de ça que pour la
fonction publique
nous avons eu des combats de la
fonctionnaire et des salaires c'est la
tempête et ben oui mais moi je trouve
que évidemment qu'il faut ne pas
individualiser c'est complètement normal
et que les choses n'est pas que de
l'automaticité que chacun s'y retrouve
et d'ailleurs c'est la même chose pour
le privé que pour le public simplement
mettons nous d'accord bien sûr des
critères qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
objectifs et dans lesquels les
fonctionnaires peuvent se montrer on
apprend que la france
de par sa situation de la situation des
fonctionnaires est une exception en
europe où ses proches je pense qu'il
faut peut-être
regardez tous à assouplir mettons de la
souplesse dans tout ça mais tant de la
vie mettant de la souplesse ça je pense
on peut qu'on peut il travailler de
faire emmanuel macron avec sa fameuse
robe accroît la loi makrouds oui mais si
j'avais été député j'aurais voté sa loi
je vais vous dire mais regardez le pays
où on parle
vous parliez de la france à l'instant on
a mis un an on a débattu un an au sénat
à l'assemblée a assemblé au sénat de la
loi macron résultat des courses
super on pouvait les magasins dimanche
au lieu de cinq jours douze jours donc
une année pour ça est ce que vous vous
rendez compte
pendant ces le salon et la mettons que
ça va pas il ya quelque chose qui marche
pas et on a le droit de faire du
transport par autocar sur les routes une
année pour ça pendant ce temps-là renzi
en italie la réformer le marché du
travail en son année il a réformé le
code du travail
il a réformé son senna qui évidemment je
place godart donnons la parole à cette
version c'est ce que je disais donc en
france et cette famille d'avant la
france quelques exceptions les réformes
masse extrêmement doucement et on a en
permanence une espèce dhabi entre ce qui
est annoncé et ce qui est fait à la fin
c'est à dire que la montagne accouche
très souvent d'une tout petit petit
petit peu importe les gouvernements et
peu importe les gouvernements il moi
c'est ça que je vais changer parce que
je veux qu'on soit utile efficace pour
les français complique retrouvé au fond
un instrument de puissance politique
vous habitez français allez on passe au
mercredi 11 novembre
11 novembre c'est le jour des cérémonies
bien évidemment et françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy ont assisté ensemble aux
commémorations de ce 11 novembre une
poignée main assez brève nicolas sarkozy
qui pouvait parfois avait accepté cette
année l'invitation protocolaire à la
cérémonie moment on va dire d'unité
nationale marielle de sarnez
ils peuvent pas vivre l'un sans l'autre
alors il ya deux choses dans sa
rapidement 1
c'est absolument normal qui est une
continuité de l'état et je trouve que
derrière cette grille ce lot d'avantagés
peut-être pour d'autres occasions aussi
ça c'est la protège la deuxième chose
mais on voit bien que l'un et l'autre ça
leur va très très bien d'être ensemble
quoi hollande votre sarkozy sarkozy vote
hollande et que tous les deux ils se
disent l'un marange l'autre marange est
fragile ce tandem là ça les arrange et
en même temps il ya quelque chose chez
eux dans ce couple là ils veulent chacun
très sarkozy veut prendre sa revanche
sur hollande et hollande va retrouver
sarkozy à la prochaine élection
présidentielle moi c'est exactement
scénario dont j'ai pas envie donc c'est
exactement le scénario que je voudrais
changer
et d'ailleurs je pense que je suis pas
la seule ce que je pense qu'il ya des
millions de français des millions de
français qui ont pas envie de ce même
scénario là qui n'ont pas envie de
refaire l'élection de la dernière fois
avec le tandem sarkozy alors je vous
proposais un sondage sud radio et ifop
vendredi si françois bayrou se présenter
nicolas sarkozy aussi le front national
assez loin devant quand même il faut le
dire donc dans ce cas de figure la
droite pourrait peut-être éventuellement
vous accusés d'être les responsables de
la montée du front national
saab est la question de la montée du
front national c'est une question très
importante
je pense qu'on a tous à y répondre
absolument tous et qu'il va falloir que
la classe politique décide un jour
peut-être les changements qu'elle doit
opérer pour essayer de répondre je
parlais tout à l'heure de renouer avec
une efficacité public que ça serve à
quelque chose que nos parlements que nos
débats démocratiques soit une étude mais
pas les deux
et la prise de responsabilités que moi
je voudrais pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle c'est qu'elle soit utile
au pays
qu'elle soit utile donc c'est à dire
qu'on change la donne
c'est à dire qu'on change le logiciel
qu'on remplace pas simplement x y ou y
par x qu'on change la manière de
gouverner prix que ce soit là mais c'est
considère qu alain juppé est un bon
candidat de ce point de vue là parce
qu'alain juppé est un candidat qui vous
le voit bien c'est pas un candidat
partisans parce qu'il y en a je veux
dire que le président de la république
soit se comporte comme chef de parti
qu'ils soient de droite ou qu'ils soient
de gauche
tout ça c'est pas l'esprit la 5e et
c'est pas bon pour le pays donc oui il
faut des présidents la république qu'ils
soient rassembleurs
oui il faut des prisons la république
qui apaise et qui en même temps une
vision qu'ils sachent où aller et qui
soit en capacité de faire bouger les
lignes en capacité de rassembler de ça
bougeait cette classe politique et je
pense qu'alain juppé
je pense qu'alain juppé a ces qualités
là est en tous les cas c'est son
positionnement politique
après la question c'est la question des
primaires est-ce que c'est lui qui
sortira des primaires entre parenthèses
moi je suis quelqu'un je suis pas très
favorable au système des primaires donc
c'est absolument contraires aux
institutions de la vème qui à deux tours
et que ces deux tours au fond ça faisait
office pour choisir au premier tour le
bon candidat
donc j'espère qu'il sortira en tête des
primaires si ça n'était pas le cas eh
bien nous l'avons toujours dit avec
françois bayrou nous prendrions nos
responsabilités alors je voudrais vous
parler d'une autre personnalité laurent
fabius puisque cette semaine la presse
allemande a révélé que le ministre
français des affaires étrangères avait
été espionnée par le renseignement
extérieur allemand tollé au sein de la
diplomatie française mais pourtant chez
les initions sait bien que tout le monde
espionne tout le monde la france sans
doute et espionnent aussi l'allemagne
pourquoi autant de réactions indignées
écoutez franchement moi je suis indigné
vous êtes un veinard mais pas seulement
là angela merkel elle est elle même
écouté par les américains il ya quelques
mois
bref on a le sentiment que les grandes
oreilles est d'accord mais tout le monde
n'est pas nouveau eh ben c'est pas une
raison pour s'en satisfaire
il ya plein de choses comme ça dans la
vie qui sont d'évidence dont je ne me
satisfais pas et contre lesquels j'ai
envie de lutter comme il ya un minimum
quand même des tic dans tout ça
quand on voit des opérateurs
téléphoniques ils doivent être à mon
avis qu'ils doivent marcher avec dans
toutes ces combines là ça marche pas il
faut des vraies démocraties
parlementaires il faut des contrôles
sont les services secrets et se laissa
bis défense comme ça se fait dans les
grandes démocraties et il faut que ce
genre de choses soit interdite
prohiber impossible il faut arrêter avec
tout ça et en plus au passage en général
s'est révélée par des lanceurs d alerte
qui vous font bien honnêtement là qui
sont dans leurs responsabilités et
qu'ils sont dans leur mission mais on en
a ras-le-bol de voir des scandale après
scandale
mois après mois des grands cris là vous
avez raison et puis derrière rien ne
change
s'allier à yann se passe ça continue
exactement comme avant pas tout ça va
pas alors je dis un ancien premier
ministre fait parler de lui on retourne
à l'actualité parlementaire
l'amendement vise à fusionner une partie
de la prime d'activité avec la csg des
foyers les plus modestes il a été
présenté par jean marc ayrault et voté
dans un hémicycle quasi désert 56
députés présents la disposition est
présenté comme un premier pas vers une
fusion entre l'impôt sur le revenu et
csg compte rendu de séance avec françois
rollin pour 35 contre 21 l'assemblée
nationale a adopté
pari gagné pour jean marc ayrault son
amendement vient d'être approuvé par les
députés
il prévoit une baisse de la csg pour les
salaires compris entre 1 et 1,3 smic
là il s'agit de d'aller plus loin dans
le sens de la baisse des impôts c'est
une mesure claire simple et qui se verra
sur la feuille de paye au 1er janvier
nous avons calculé que ça pouvait
représenter une augmentation de pouvoir
d'achat mensuel pour les salariés payés
au smic autour de 100 euros
je lis bien 100 euros ce n'est pas rien
la mesure assez populaire à gauche a
séduit jusque sur les bancs des fronts
même si des députés socialistes ont émis
quelques doutes mais je n'ai trouvé
aucun élément favorable aux salariés il
n'y aura pas un euro de revenu
disponible de plus il y aura par contre
un revenu fiscal de référence qui peut
augmenter de 4 35 à 5 % qui l'année
suivante mais pourrait conduire à des
baisses davantage fiscaux des baisses
davantage sociaux à droite lui dei comme
les républicains s'opposent à ce texte
vu par l'opposition comme une hausse
d'impôt déguisée les classes moyennes
qui ont déjà très chèrement payé votre
politique fiscale vont encore plus payer
il faut bien que les gens comprennent qu
effectivement si vous dites diminué des
impôts d'un côté sachant que les
dépenses du gouvernement ne vont pas en
diminuant soit extrêmement importante
c'est bien les classes moyennes celles
qui font la richesse de notre pays celle
qui paye tout le temps qu'ils vont
encore plus payer vos propositions et
vos propositions de bricolage le
gouvernement qui avait refusé de
soutenir l'amendement n'a donc pas été
suivi après une après-midi de débat le
texte ne fait plus mention de l'impôt
citoyen la fameuse fusion impôt sur le
revenu csg qui figuraient à l'origine
dans l'amendement
là on parle beaucoup de fusion ces
derniers temps et je puisais parce que
celle ci selon vous va réussir
goûter avec 56 députés c'est terrible
vous voyez un peu l'état de notre
démocratie parlementaire tout ça n'est
pas raisonnable d'ailleurs on a déjà
entre parenthèses je voudrais partager
l'art comme très vite qu'on ait enfin
des parlements un jour qui ressemble au
pays c'est à dire qu'il présente
l'ensemble des courants politiques du
pays y compris d'ailleurs ce combat
comme le front national
on voit bien que tout ça cette
démocratie parlementaire elle ne
fonctionne pas ou savait qu'on est quand
même le seul pays de l'europe
continentale avoir le mode de scrutin
que nous avons est le seul pays à ne pas
réformer
je referme ce fonds est ce que ce soit
la csg cette mesure n'est pas bonne
qu'est ce qui a été voté hier n'est pas
bon par ailleurs c'est une usine à gaz
il ya le vice président de la commission
des finances ne dit pas autre chose
ayrault dit ça va rapporter 100 euros
chaque mois à huy intéressant et le vice
président la commission des finances ni
pas du tout parce que comme on va
supprimer la prime d'activité ça
rapportera rien du tout c'est que moi je
crois que la csg est un bon impôt que
c'est un impôt universel
je suis d'ailleurs pour l'impôt
universel
je considère que l'impôt sur le revenu
doit être payée par tout le monde même
d'une façon très petit problème d'une
façon symbolique et que sortir en
permanence des français de l'impôt et la
de la csg en quelque sorte c'est faire
peser l'ensemble ou font des recettes
nécessaires au fonctionnement de l'état
sur toujours les mêmes c'est à dire
toujours les classes moyennes donc la
csg c'est un bon impôt universel il faut
pas y toucher ou penser que le conseil
constitutionnel va ruiner la mesure oui
je le crois pas ce que vous pensez que
c'est une mesure d' inégalité fiscale
pense est une mesure d' inégalité
fiscale je pense que c'est une mesure
qui est bricolé pour des raisons que
j'ignore
j'ignore ce que c'est un cadeau à la
gauche de la gauche pour les régionales
oui probablement est-ce que jean marc
ayrault tout d'un coup veux je ne sais
pas à se positionner pour quelque chose
je il ya quelque chose d accord je dans
tous afin que mais arrêtons de jouer
avec la fiscalité la fiscalité les
impôts les français en ont soupé ils en
ont ras-le-bol
ils ne croient plus les promesses quand
on leur dit vous allez avoir ce encore
plus par mois ça n'est pas vrai c'est
simplement faux et donc tout ça ne va
pas les choses qui marchent la csg c'est
un impôt qui marche 20 gars dont le
cabinet et puis réfléchissons à rendre
l'impôt sur le revenu universel dans une
vraie réforme fiscale
alors on va passer au sénat cette fois
on a parlé beaucoup de la reine des
migrants cette semaine et depuis de
nombreuses semaines savait qu'en france
la ville de calais forme de symbole de
ce problème au sénat le ministre de
l'intérieur a tenu à réaffirmer le rôle
de l'état et s'en prend à ceux qui
caricaturent écouter cet échange aux
questions d'actualité autre militant
intérieur bernard cazeneuve et la
sénatrice esther benbassa en visite au
cra de paris vincennes j'ai rencontré
des gens perdus et ses nus et humilié
n'ayant rien à faire là arrêté dans les
gares parisiennes pour empêcher leur
départ vers calais monsieur le ministre
qu'en sera-t-il mis mis fin à une
manipulation attentatoire à la dignité
des personnes étaient à ternissant
l'image de la france votre préoccupation
madame benbassa c'est comme celle
d'autres d'ailleurs qui sont plutôt de
ce côté de celui de 7 m
non non rassurez vous je ne parle pas de
vous je parle de ceux qui sont en haut
et à l'extrême droite et de ceux qui
parfois leur emboîtent le pas c'est
d'instrumentaliser la question
migratoire d'instrumentaliser la
question migratoire à des fins
politiques plutôt que de dire la vérité
ce que sur ce que nous faisons tout
simplement parce que ce pays et la
france et qu'en france on réserve les
meilleures conditions d'asile à ceux qui
ont droit à l'asile en france
je vous entends dire cela mais pour cela
il aurait fallu vous convoquer dans
votre question
la vérité on était loin de la vérité
alors marielle de sarnez vous connaissez
bien la situation et notamment aussi
dans cette jungle de calais est ce que
pour vous bernard cazeneuve et liste de
l'intérieur et l'homme de la situation
c'est plutôt un bon ministre de
l'intérieur il a été avant ministre en
charge des affaires européennes et j'ai
de l'estimé pour lui cette question des
réfugiés et de la migration est une
question extrêmement lourdes et convient
vraiment cueillez pas de récupération de
politique politicienne il convient de ne
pas instrumentaliser tout ça ce sont des
questions lourdes qui seront devant nous
pour très longtemps il il reconnaît
quand même que la situation est
totalement bloquée à cannes allemand
mais je vais vous dire je simple vous
dire cette question elle est très lourde
et pour longtemps et il n'y a pas un
politique les politiques qui vous disent
moi j'arrive je règle la question il ya
plus de flux migratoires il ya plus de
flux de réfugiés vous raconte des
histoires ce sont des menteurs vous
aurez beau construire tous les murs du
monde
la question des migrations et des
réfugiés car si toi donc il faut qu'on
change de politique sur tout ça sur
calais il ya eu des accords passés les
fameux accords du touquet qu'est ce
qu'ils disent et accord du touquet bas
ils disent nous la grande bretagne qu'on
sauve au dos nous actons et nous
demandons à la france de gérer nos flux
migratoires tout ça ne va pas tout ça
n'est pas je veux dire il faut qu'on
change là aussi le logiciel la grande
bretagne elle doit gérer ces demandeurs
d'asile l'allèle hrw elle doit aller
voir oui mais pardon mais dès qu'elle
refuse
moi je il faut faire un bras de fer avec
eux il faut arriver à trouver une
solution
tous ceux qui sont à calais c'est pour
rejoindre des familles qui disent qu'ils
sont en grande bretagne c'est pas pour
rester en france la grande bretagne peut
pas considérer mais je reconnais que
c'est les accords du touquet 2003 alors
il faut peut-être les repenser il faut
plonger à la 40 s'appuie sur wii
pourrait très bien alors dénonçons les
il faut qu'on repense tout cela ils sont
5000 6000
eh bien écoutez que les la grande
bretagne que les anglais essaye de
regarder dossier par dossier
le mieux d'ailleurs c'est de regarder
les dossiers de demande de visa avant
que les gens soient sur le territoire
européen pardonnez moi mais c'est de
faire les choses dans les pays de départ
quand on le peut là je parle pas des
réfugiés de la syrie ouidah mans c'est
impossible dans les pays de départ quand
on le peut de donner ou pas un droit de
venir et une présomption d'asile ou pas
et de reconduire ce qui ne relève pas du
droit d'asile et tout ça c'est aussi aux
anglais de le faire c'est pas à la
france de gérer tout seul
la demande migratoire le flux
migratoires à l'avant du corps comme un
michael
ceci n'empêche pas d'avoir des
conditions décentes à calais et je dois
dire que la france république française
quand on voit cette jungle de calais
tout ça il ya quelque chose qui parle on
parle avec la grande bretagne
on règle le problème un parent c'est pas
en les mettant dans des avions ou dans
des centres de rétention quelques jours
relâchés ensuite par la justice revenant
ensuite à calais qu'on réglera implique
c'est le négociant ouvrons des
négociations ils sont pas dans l'espace
de schengen très bien mais c'est pas la
france de gérer la pression migratoire
sur la grande bretagne
je pose en une du jir assez sur son
partenaire du tout d'abord on en vient à
la loupe du scan
jim c'est à vous on va parler de
l'émission de françois bayrou qui était
hier sur le plateau de des paroles et
des actes sur france 2 alors il a répété
qu'il ne voulait pas d'une
présidentielle opposant à nouveau
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy marie
le pen qu'il était prêt à faire face à
ces impasses ce sont ses mots et à feu
voilà et a donc peut-être se présenter
en 2017
est ce qu'un responsable politique qui a
été candidat trois fois déjà à la
présidentielle peut incarner une
candidature de renouveau peut incarner
une candidature d'alternative selon vous
marielle de sarnez
on peut reprendre la question peut-être
au début ça vous échappe pas que nous
sommes prêts et françois bayrou le
premier à soutenir alain juppé vous avez
saisi ça que c'est d'ailleurs je le note
au passage rare qu'un homme politique de
premier plan
c'est françois bayrou a quand même une
faune la confiance de beaucoup de
français aujourd'hui qu'un homme
politique de premier plan disent qu'il
est prêt à soutenir un autre homme
politique c'est moi je connais pas
d'autres exemples dans la vie politique
française cela donc je trouve que de ce
point de vue là c'est intéressant et
pourquoi il est prêt à soutenir alain
juppé bas pour ce que j'ai essayé
d'expliquer tout à l'heure on a besoin
de changer la donne politique dans ce
pays
et donc on a besoin d'avoir un président
rassembleur un président qui apaise qui
porte une vision qui soit à même de
conduire le pays est de conduire au fond
les changements nécessaires pour que les
français pour que les français vivent
mieux
bah oui oui oui c'est bien qu'ils aient
des nouvelles têtes
emmanuel macron il existe et c'est bien
oui mais justement peut-être quelques
fois on a besoin et de nouvelles têtes
et d'expériences et la garantie qu est
ce qui fait qu alain juppé est
plébiscité aujourd'hui dans les sondages
c'est bien sûr les qualités personnelles
qui sont les siennes
mais ça aussi justement son âge
paradoxalement 1 les gens se disent il a
de l'expérience il sera sage et sera
peut-être pas la drôme 8 est plus là
pour nous c'est très bien tout ça c'est
intéressant je trouve peut-être due
aussi au rejet de
nicolas sarkozy comme de françois
hollande bien sûr vous voyez bien que
nicolas sarkozy françois hollande
aujourd'hui ce sont les deux
personnalités qui sont le plus emballé
le moins apprécié des français dans les
sondages pour autant qu'on puisse me
viole sa après ils ont des raisons
différents sarkozy a un noyau dur
peut-être françois hollande un petit
noyau je sais pas s'il sera dire ou pas
l'un c'est peut-être pour sa politique
l'autre c'est peut-être pour sa
personnalité on peut ensuite continuer
longtemps
après ça veut pas dire qu'ils ne sont
pas candidats l'un et l'autre donc ça va
être ça toute la question de l'année qui
va s'ouvrir et qui va venir devant nous
mais au delà de la question des
primaires on y reviendra dessus je pense
que c'est très important moi j'ai
vraiment jeu tout mon engagement d'aller
dans les mois qui vont venir ça sera de
faire en sorte que la présidentielle
prochaine soit vraiment utile que ce
soit pas un mandat de plus à blanc que
ça soit pas un mandat de plus où on est
à chaque fois réglé aucun des problèmes
des français
moi j'ai envie de changer
parlons un peu des élections régionales
le modem a choisi la stratégie
d'alliance on l'a dit avec les
républicains sa peur d'être facile par
tout cela dit on l'a vu en auvergne et
rhône-alpes pardon le modem se s'est
divisée un peu sur son soutien à laurent
wauquiez non notre chef de file patrick
mignola s'est allié avec l'invention
s'est allié avec laurent wauquiez abbas
était pas évident du tout parce que
laurent wauquiez a priori sur ses
positions par exemple européenne ya eu
des interrogations
et ce quand il a donné ces données
nature écoutez si vous vous assemblez
rassembler qu'avec des gens qui sont
exactement les mêmes qui pensent
exactement la même chose que vous vous
n'avez pas forcément de capacité de
rassemblement large il faut des
rassemblements larges il en faudra pour
le pays après la présidentielle et il en
faut aux élections régionales alors ce
rassemblement large vous en faites
partie en ile de france puisque vous
êtes candidate sur les lignes ce
monsieur je suis en dernière position
soit la liste gandhi pas voilà pousser
la liste est moyennement soutiennent pas
si on attendit date à être conseillère
régionale c'est ça le roulèr été clair
en position éligible le ps a dénoncé
cette semaine la présence de plusieurs
proches de la manif pour tous sur les
listes de
huit candidats sont notamment issus de
sens commun c'est le mouvement anti
mariage qui associé à l'ump
est ce que ça vous pose problème a dit
c'est pas ma sensibilité
mais ça ne me pose aucun problème quoi
il faudrait mettre sur une liste que des
gens qui pensent tous pareils qui ont la
même tête que le même physique comme le
même adn mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
il ya dans cette manière de penser la
politique de la part des socialismes
alors je reviens c'est les campagnes et
campagne ça permet pas tout c'est une
espèce de sectarisme de préjugés comme
ça tu que sont les uns les autres
c'est un délit de penser comme ça qu'on
accole aux uns aux autres et tout ça
sympa je pense qu'ils perdent leurs
nerfs de ce point de vue là que ce n'est
pas raisonnable de faire ce type de
procès je trouve que valérie pécresse
c'est une très bonne candidate
elle est légitime pour la région et pas
seulement d'aujourd'hui ça fait des
années qu'elle parcourt cette région
elle aime cette région je pense qu'elle
sera une très bonne présidente de région
parce qu'elle a montré dans cette
campagne et elle monte dans cette
campagne une capacité à rassembler une
capacité à ouvrir largement justement
vous et pour moi la présidente de région
ça doit être quelqu'un qui s'adresse
d'une belle à l'ancien des franciliens
ce qu'elle doit rassembler jusqu'à
nicolas du pognon c'est que ni pourrait
peut-être attendre la barre symbolique
de 10% qui lui permet d'être là viendra
pas je crois que les franciliens verrons
bien qu'il ya un vote utile au fond au
premier tour et un bulletin qui est
celui du vote utile si on veut le
changement dans la région et pour moi il
faut un changement pour la vie
quotidienne des franciliens dans la
région ces de marie pécresse
jamais le latin est ce que les listes de
fait les rebelles je vienne nous
rejoindre
le vote utile pour moi non mais c'est
une hypothèse que je retiens pas je
pense que les franciliens ne se
tromperont pas ils ont pour tous ceux
qui veulent que ça change que ça bouge
qu'on trouve des stages pour ses enfants
et pour ses mômes qu'on trouve de
l'emploi que la région soit au service
des pme
qu'on soit mieux transporter et pas
transporter comme on l'est aujourd'hui
et je pourrais continuer la liste
longuement bahia un vocable du projet
valérie pécresse donc campagne au centre
et à droite campagne au sein de campagne
à droite campagne aux déçus de la gauche
campagne à ceux qui se reconnaissent pas
dans le sectarisme du candidat de la
gauche
oui c'est ça la campagne qu'il faut
mener dans les
même s'ils viennent une campagne pour
les franciliens merci à vous merci jim
jarrassé et on retrouve la semaine
prochaine et nous on va prendre tout un
peu de recul
si vous le voulez bien loin de la
politique immédiate avec les souvenirs
très ému d'un ancien président de la
république que vous connaissez bien
valéry giscard d'estaing s'est livré à
frédéric mitterrand sur la vie politique
sur son propre destin
conversations inédites diffusées sur
notre antenne extraits
qu est-ce qu au fond vous sentez bien
dans cette société française
d'aujourd'hui est ce qu'elle vous
intéresse
réponse non
la société française qui m'intéressait
je la vois disparaître
ça m'a vraiment disparaître comme le
spectacle dans un film dont on broie
quelque chose c'est juste une société
plus organisées plus orageuses acceptant
son long passé historique à les
acrobaties zurich
considérant qu'il doit y avoir des
efforts que rien ne peut se faire sans
effort écartant l'obsession des vacances
et de l'information à tout prix
donc non je ne suis pas heureux dans
cette société je préfère de société 2
juste avant j'ai un très beau poème vous
vous prenez ces baudelaire pourquoi est
ce qu'il est là dans votre esprit parce
qu'il a toujours été gelée entendu qu'en
première fois
franchement les oncles frère de mon père
d'une circonstance on compte le lisais
le site est tellement marquée que je
m'en suis toujours souvenu ce qui est
beau c'est la fin mais le vert paradis
des amours enfantines les courses les
chansons
les baisers et les bosquets et les
violons vélo rang derrière les collines
avec les bronzes 20 le soir dans les
mosfets vous êtes vous avez très aimé qu
est ce qui vous reste de cette époque de
cet engagement
moi je les aime beaucoup et c'est pas
que je suis ému parce que je sens dans
la manière dont il parle est dans son
émotion la danse et quelques quelques
mots de baudelaire au fond du temps qui
a été du temps qui a été le sien d'un
tank et qui est derrière quelque peu le
nôtre et ils auraient aimé je pense que
ça ne change jamais que ce que ça reste
comme ça
il a été très jeune président de la
république française on a du mal à
envisager ce que ça a été à l'époque
moi je dis toujours c'était comme la
transformation le passage de la télé en
noir et blanc à la télé en couleur
c'était vraiment le passage de deux
mondes et on sent chez lui
7 oui cette nostalgie de ceux de ce
moment là qu est un moment de
modernisation de la france formidable
auquel il faudra rendre justice un jour
je trouve que on lui doit lui doit
beaucoup
merci ce sera donc la numéro de la drive
vous êtes vite à voir ce reportage ces
documentaires diffusés le 23 et 30
novembre sur notre antenne placée avoir
suivi la semaine prochaine